révisez messieurs bonjour après des mois
des semaines des jours des minutes des
secondes on va faire l'inversé des
seconds des minutes des jours des
semaines des mois des années où vous me
dites dans les commentaires fabien c'est
quand tu fais excalibur le casse tête ex
quelle excuse
excalibur excalibur télé but c'est quand
que tu fais de castets excalibur
la réponse est aujourd'hui des records
en fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui il était
introuvable et maintenant il hérite du
coup il est trouvable par contre ils
sont ils sont clairement plaisir au
niveau du prix je les trouvais gelé reçu
je me suis jamais spa hull sur les
vidéos de crise tram c'est je crois
qu'amy star puzzle aussi qu'il l'a fait
bref à chaque fois j'ai jamais cliqué
donc j'ai pas vu le seul truc que j'ai
vu c'est qu'ils ont fait plusieurs
épisodes
donc je me dis il doit être bien coriace
non mesdames et messieurs je vous
présente le casse-tête le plus dur
jamais fait sur cette chaîne loïc
bonjour tu vas bientôt en ce moment bah
moi mais coûte c'est gentil de demander
ben ça va justement là en fait ça va ça
va je te dis ça mais ça ne coule
d'accord on est cool mais tu n'as pas
laisser permet du coup tu sais pas alors
le risque générique hebinger génériques
alors génériques
je vous le disais il ya quelques
secondes c'est de castets le plus dure
que j'ai jamais fait et un des plus durs
qui a été construit l'idée c'est
d'enlever lés p [ __ ] tu imagines c'est
là qu'elle bien bombe a terminé donc non
c'est à dessouder un blog comme ça en
bois l'idée n'est pas de refaire le
casse tête alors oui certains vont se
dire ouais mais fabien je croyais qu'il
y avait un casse tête n'est vraiment
fait que quand il est refait web est pas
là là on va d'abord se faire étape une
le dépouiller on verra à faire une étape
2 je sais pas si je pourrai le faire en
une seule vidéo évidemment avant de
commencer à péter un câble je vous donne
l'information du jour le numéro 3 de
curieuses va sortir peut-être même il
est déjà sorti au moment où vous voyez
la vidéo voici un petit visuel de la
couverture c'est toujours un magazine de
40h vous pouvez toujours vous abonner et
je réponds à une question globale
écoutez là même si vous n'êtes pas
abonné c'est important pour l'instant
vous allez avoir le curieuse numéro 3 en
version digitale dans votre espace sur
cursus point fr mais vous recevrez la
version papier en même temps que le
numéro 4 ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
prévu comme pour l'instant tout est à
l'arrêt
on voulait pas vous faire attendre donc
vous avez déjà comme ça accès aux trois
vous pouvez lire mais après vous
recevrez bien sûr la version papier
c'était important de le préciser
et si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à
curieuse je vous le dis les retours
qu'on a ils sont très très cool à la
hauteur de ce que j'espérais donc
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
ces corps news.fr si vous avez une
question il ya tout sur curieuse point
fr vous pouvez changer votre adresse de
réception autant de fois vous voulez
dans votre espace privé et c'est un
magazine mensuel 10 numéros par an parce
que il ya deux mois où ça couvre deux
mois et c'est au prix de 29 euros 90
soit moins de 2 euros 50 par mois
donc en clair c'est moins cher qu'à un
tipi et en plus vous avez un magazine de
40 pages tous les mois bref
abonnez vous en cette période en plus ça
ne soutiendra pas mal tout ce que je
fais déjà 27 minutes de vidéo alors la
bestiole
comment ça se passe bon c'est assez
clair que ce sont des cubes comme ça qui
coulisse j'ai peut-être le tenir comme
ça je sais juste qu'il ya là bas je l'
ai fini en fait c'est vraiment cette
fait pas si dur du coup
c'était le jeu de le penser et de tous
sortir en fait c'était un [ __ ] les
mecs ils ont eu trois vidéos a trouvé sa
non juifs je me dis juste si je le pose
comme ça vous verrez peut-être mieux que
si je ne mets comme ça alors pourquoi la
sas a décalé comme ça par contre
ok d'accord donc en fait les bois doit
pas être forcément déçu parce que si je
lâche voilà il ya plus un qui se passe
ok il ya combien de bouts de bois là il
y en a un ça c'en est un autre donc là
il y en a deux trois quais ça ça nous
avec le même j'imagine ça doit faire 4 5
6 7 8 taille avis il ya huit bouts de
bois à la bâche sais pas comment ils
sont imbriqués mais ça doit y aller mon
gars ok bon bah on va commencer à faire
comme tout le monde je pense que dire au
pif si lui je pousse vers lui je peux le
descendre d'un cran
voilà clairement du coup sa mamie
berckois et ça me libère les deux que
vous voyez bouger la fin du coup c'est
pas mal de le tenir comme ça et ça me
libère aussi un peu lui il va falloir
comprendre à eau
c'est bien ça ça c'est bien mon petit
papa c'est bien de voir dans le casse
tête apparemment ça m'éclate
non mais en vrai c'est parce que
regarder là je vois un peu à l'intérieur
comment les pièces sans usines donc
c'est pas mal pour peut-être que
j'utilise un truc pour m'en souvenir
j'invoque mes potes qui chante loïc
short pour les post it le post it prend
le 6 3 le post quitteront le petit truc
style des verts est comme ça avec les
post-it j'étais de dessiner la forme que
je vois tu vois ce que je veux dire pour
pour mieux bon face au bo les couilles
tiens je crois que c'est juste un truc
qui fait comme ça bonjour je crois que
la pièce à l'intérieur elle fait juste
une sorte de y comme ça et comme ça tu
vois je vais mettre là et comme ça eh
bien je m'en souviendrai noter cette
friterie sur dix dans les commentaires
vous pouvez noter que des nombres à
virgule galère lui tenir pour l'enlever
du coup il faudra clairement
e tout va se bloquer tout le temps en
fait c'est très très dur de pouvoir bien
raisonner mais lui pour pouvoir
l'enlever il faudra que lui la nuit soit
enlevé donc
intéressons nous à lui lui pour pouvoir
l'enlever faudra que lui faudra que
l'ubs il soit poussée va que lui je le
pousse pour pouvoir enlever celui-là
faudrait clairement que eux deux ils
soient poussées ou enlever évidemment
mais du coup je vais peut-être essayé de
pousser lui vers le bas puis pour le
pousser vers le bas à bas je peux en
plus et pourquoi c'était céder quoi mon
idée drh et c'est déjà plus moi je
compte dans le monde il existe des mecs
qui ont pris une revanche sur la vie en
se disant je vais créer des casse têtes
qui vont faire péter des câbles aux gens
comme ça ça va bien les calmer en fait
c'est fifou des gens qui n'aiment pas
les filles fou de base vous fait voir
l'intérieur un peu là ce qui est en
train de se passer
ah oui donc lui les îles et l'usiné oi
au hockey oui les usines et celle où en
fait voilà lui l'huile
il est un peu comme ça celui ci la voyez
un peu le dell dell quoi tâche
je me demande si c'est pas ce genre de
truc un peu tarabiscoté qu'il faudra
sortir en premier du coup je voudrais
pouvoir le recul est à oui parce que en
plus dans sa forme 3d
l'aca agrippant fait et non pas à grid
parce que la grippe c'est un ogre dans
harry potter donc ça vaut vraiment un
art qu'il y en avoir mais mais il
agrippe ça donc ça veut dire que quoi
qu'il arrive faudra réussir à le plus
c'est qu'en profondeur comme il devait
l'être d'ailleurs j'imagine le départ
parce qu'au départ elle n'était pas
comme ça ça va être très très dur de
faire un suivi
il va falloir tâtonner pour réussir à
sortir le tout premier il est bloqué là
lui les blocs et là ça c'est quoi ça
c'est lui
waouh si loïc était là il serait pas
chez lui c'est important de comprendre
si loïc était là il serait pas chez lui
je pense qu'on va pouvoir partir mon
cher loïc du futur sur une accélération
parce que pour l'instant faux faux faux
avancé tâtonner jusqu'à temps de trouver
quelque chose qui soit intéressant parce
que là tout ce que j'ai réussi à faire
jusqu'à maintenant c'est de quasiment
revenir dans la position initiale du
casse-tête et ben voila j'ai réussi à
remettre excalibur en place je serais
fier c'est ouf de la voir autant
manipuler pour caen 2 secondes après
sarr face ça alors écoutez cher monsieur
du 22 c'est lolo du 22 c'est le vrai nom
de loïc jauneau 10 22 j'en appelle à
l'accélération
[Musique]
je vous le dis je viens de comprendre
quelque chose je coupe de secondes
l'accélération en plein milieu du
casse-tête là le bout de bois que vous
apercevez peut-être en classe entre les
traversant et qui est plein en poche
c'est la suite d'excalibur et ça fait
bouger jusqu en dessous jusqu'ici en
fait ça veut dire que sur le trajet il
ya un truc que je ne peux pas bouger
ah oui d'accord
ah ok la jeune clairement de faire des
sondés ce cri ali ben hur sais pas si ça
va m'aider à quelque chose ou pas mais
comme vous comme vous le voyez j'ai pu
le descendre un petit rang comme ça ça
va peut-être nous offrir de nouvelles
possibilités
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on aimerait on
n'a jamais vu le gast est aussi clair
jusqu'à présent la en tout cas on voit
un peu mieux ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
alors imaginons que je m'intéresse à
deux fois toi tu es là était là ou à toi
toi tu es là était là toi pour ça il
faudrait que lui puisse descendre plus
que pas le cas la fraise en fait
vraiment le logo l'idéal c'est de
pouvoir en sortir
un quoi pas sûr que ce fut une bonne
idée de sortir avec 6,2 de faire
descendre excalibur d'un cran j'arrive
toujours à le remonter
et toi t'es qui toi tu appartiens
quelqu'un toi ou tu es juste un bout du
doigt comme ça qui fait iech je
m'appelle jean michel bout de bois
depuis l'intervention de fabien olicard
je ne sais plus quoi faire j'avais un
but une raison d'exister bien au chaud
dans excalibur
vous voilà vous un vous avez géré ce
vote déclare tout cas ce n'est pas parce
que c'est vrai non je ne sais pas dans
la boîte de chair cap l'amour lui tape
contre qui les ait ap contre excalibur
donc déjà quoi qu'il arrive il pourrait
pas passer
il faudrait que ça l'a lui ne peut pas
être sortis pour le monde parce qu'il a
une encoche si j'arrive à le mettre là
serait peut-être pas mal ce qui pourrait
l'empêcher de décembre ah ok quoi qu'il
arrive c'est lui qui n'empêche de
descente
parce que lui je peux monter je peux
monter si lui et machin lui je le pousse
prost oncle et qui va me détester parce
que j'ai la tête qui rentrent dans le
truc à chaque fois à chaque fois faut
trouver qui est impliqué dans le blocage
de l'auto donc ça c'est que ce calibre
on pas que je vois c'est excellent lui
aurait sorti toi on comprend pas on
comprend pas comment comment sont reliés
les boues le bout de bois ensemble lui
il n'avance pas parce qu'il ya lui lui
c'est lui c'est celui du centre et sidi
sans a priori je ne peux pas de tirer
mais on sait pas vraiment pourquoi
bâle s'est on est on est on est pas sur
la bonne piste
on va on va attaquer un autre
[Musique]
mais quoi qu'il arrive excalibur va
toujours bloquée parce que l'excalibur à
un bout de bois transversale centrale
qui par-delà jusque là donc c'est
complètement impossible
il va vraiment falloir je pense à un
moment donné faim manipulation de
bascule ça va jamais venir comme un
comme un simple tiroirs suppose si je
suis bien clair dans ce que dit si je
tiens l'ensemble comme ça vous voyez
comment j'arrive à à bouger la pièce on
voit que j'arrive à la mettre de côté
ben je crois que c'est comme ça qu'il va
falloir sortir une pièce en la
manipulant un peu en lui tel un
serpentin c'est pas simple j'ai pas du
tout comment je vais faire mais c'est
pas mal que là je vois bien qu'il manque
pas beaucoup de jeu pour que je puisse
faire les manipulations qui me
permettrait de sortir celle là il
faudrait que lui soit plus que lui
soient plus poussé là pour que j'ai un
petit peu d'air pour mettre le coup dé
contourner la barre est d'excalibur
c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut mon but
serait de 2 pouces et plus donc si je le
monte parce que c'est possible ça non
pas possible le montant dommage
mais pourquoi c'est pas possible dans
mon temps parce qu'il ya à lui qui
m'emmerde
et lui c'est lui
là il est il est à fondre donc ça veut
dire que si je le repousse lui ouais
c'est que serpent qui se vend le qui se
vend le plus
ce parc est pas si j'essayais al'inverse
de le faire passer comme ça il est
comment son creux de ce côté
qu'un statut un peu dur du monde
[Musique]
à
en fait lui si je voulais machine
faudrait que je pousse la donc tout ce
qui le bloque donc lui est ce que je
peux par contre le pouce et je peux le
pousse et c'est lui elle par contre
encore plus poussée doit être plus
poussée avec lui les paroles
enfin il faudrait refaire le casse-tête
à 0 à la vache tu as vu comment je peux
bouger lui là vous voyez ça moi s'il y
avait assez d'espacé pour fr claque
comme ça la claque et hop forcer un peu
elle ramenait je suis certain que c'est
la solution mais pas forcément sur cette
pièce mais mais d'une manière générale
c'est ce que c'est la bonne méthode
puisque de toute manière
l'excalibur traverse avec un bout de
bois que l'on pourrait faire ici en
pointillés que vous puissiez bien
comprendre ça part de là et ça ressort
là en fait il ya un gros bout de bois me
qui est pas amovible justement qu'est
fixe voilà si oui je pouvais pousser
[Musique]
tellement peu d espace pour y aller vous
voyez pas mais je vous mets comme ça je
pense que vous voyez bien la pièce telle
qu'elle est donc après le rendre comme
ça et là il ya un petit coup de qui tape
il ya vraiment sans déconner il ya ce
petit bout des ongles en fait qui
permettrait de claques et le sortir
quand tu quand même faire une marque sur
suis là pour me rappeler qu'il était sur
le point de sortir si si l'autre côté
est libéré et je vais essayer de
travailler ce côté là maintenant plutôt
avec ça rend ouf commence à comprendre
pourquoi tout ce qu'ils ont essayé ont
dû faire plusieurs vidéos pour le
réussir parce qu'il va falloir des
heures et des heures et des heures et
des quoi aider on doit en être à
quelques heures déjà là sur aix est
libre on va se faire une petite pause
pour aujourd'hui notre va le laisser en
l'état c'est à dire que voilà ça ça ne
se remet pas avec ce que j'ai déplacé
on a l'impression sinon que tout tout
est refait on a juste lui qui est qui a
bougé
eh bien ce sera la première vidéo
d'excalibur je pense qu'on va partir sur
une série de plusieurs parce qu'à un
moment donné en fait le cerveau il sert
un tu sais plus peut-être que je le
verrai sur un angle neuf le prochain
coup parce que là en plus je bloque
mentalement à vouloir travailler cette
partie là n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et activer la cloche pour voir le
prochain excalibur
n'oubliez pas de checker le magazine
curieuse vous pouvez lire un extrait
dans sur le site internet en fait deux
d'un dédain des trois premiers numéros
donc vous avez le lien dans la
description voilà abonnez-vous s'écoule
en vrai si les deux euros 49 par mois
sur un an d'abonnement c'est une
chouette chose et on fournit vraiment du
gros taf pour qu'il vous plaise et puis
et puis en ce ce fait la suite
d'excalibur dans pas longtemps
vous me dites dans l'est comme si ça
vous plaît en tout cas si vous voulez
voir d'autres casse-tête vous en mai a
ici qui était tout aussi relooke lui il
m'a fallu deux vidéos pour le faire et
je vous en mets a ici qui est plus
rigolo parce qu'il y avait loïc avec moi
qui essayait de le faire à très bientôt
chap